das ist
das ergebnis richtig voll das glas ja
sie wollen dass die roten sind
unverschämte fragen die grünen sind
harmlose fragen du darfst wählen
sondern alle nehmen sind ja ähnlich
viele wir können auch allen dürfte aber
das ist nicht weniger oder mehr als
sonst ach so es sind immer mehr quote
als grüne kommt nicht fangen wir mit rot
anja aber muss sie zu grünen
zwischendurch nicht langweilig also okay
so
und der gewinner
wieso machst du comedy bist du nicht gut
genug als theaterschauspieler
wollen lieber holen
also die frage stellen wo ich setze mir
gebracht er war aber manche kommen von
mir bekommen
das kommt mir die hand das lustige ist
mit das schwierigste was ein
schauspieler auf der bühne darzustellen
hat ja das ist ja natürlich jemand zum
lachen zu bringen ist um vielfaches
schwieriger als jemand zum weinen zu
bringen oder halt dramatisch zu sein das
lustige das auch funktioniert ist eine
sehr sehr hohe kunst die ich glaube ich
da liegt ein denkfehler und eine
wissenslücke zu
jetzt mal was anderes
so
woher hast du die tollen einfälle für
deine texte
aus dem leben du lebst und koks ließ
eine zeitung sie in der bild zeitung da
steht eine schlagzeile wie
warum vor vielen seen islam
lexikon über ein programmpunkt schon
wieder fünf minuten programmkino wenn
der was ich immer toll finde ist wenn
man
wenn man aus aber das ist bei denen ich
dafür ich find's toll weil kunden
geschätzt wenn man aus einem gag fünf
minuten ziehen kann das passiert nicht
aber man hat fünf wieder rausziehen
bedeuten können dass es ist ökonomisch
ja das stimmt
sind alle männer aus deiner familie so
charmant selbstverständlich
selbstverständlich ja das charme ist bei
uns in der familie ganz große gefühl
geschwister zwei
brüder schwestern ich habe zwei brüder
einen jüngeren und einen älteren ja ich
bin in der mitte okay was machen die
bestimmt wie sagt man geschäftsleute
kaufleute macht die hand vom handy laden
sie haben so die erzieherin monaten war
friseurläden und man
jüngerer bruder der der
hat so ein eisenwarenladen jetzt
übernommen solides handwerk
leidest du sehr unter dem dominanten
atze schröder ich leide ja gar nicht
unter dem sondern die figur moratti
spielen durfte hat unter schröder
gelitten obwohl die behauptung ist ja
dass die beiden dicke freunde sind
anscheinend sieht man diese freundschaft
nicht
ja das ist so funktioniert die das ist
ja eine regel der komik dass da einer
den arsch hinhalten einen schrank hat
aber ist es nicht so dass an solchen
setzt trotzdem manchmal so dieses
rollenverständnis sich auch gerne haben
also nichts und ich wir sind
ja ja ja ich liebe diesen mann ist ja
oder sagen wir der mann hinter der
hinter der maske der der er ist ein
netter dass sein sohn carl ist ja ein
riesen menschen weil es gibt in der
branche auf die sind gar nicht ja das
mag ja sein aber stand auch das ist
gesund ist wach ist klar ist ist
liebevoll ist aufmerksam es ist ein
toller typ toller typ also ich also das
kann ich leider nichts gegenteiliges
sagen
hahahaha
ja
hast du eine sonnenkopf
hast du eine sonnenallergie
ich mutmaße mal das spielt mit auf
meinen beinkleid fuß segler bei meinen
auftritten zu nein ich habe oft keine
socken in june ich habe keine
sonnenallergie
dass man den schulen das war das hat
sich mal ergeben ich hab mal über den
auftritt meine schuhe vergessen dass man
im sommer und hatte die anbindung daraus
und wasser überrascht über den effekt
denn das hatte dass da leute auch wenn
man sich damit beschäftigt haben die
ganze zeit und dann dieser kauf der
bilder immer seine freunde das ist nur
eine kommunikations angebot für all die
leute die sich nur für äußerlichkeiten
interessieren wenn du mit inhalt nicht
klar kommt man dazu viel ist völlig
überfordert bin ich schön hier ist für
jeden was dabei hier fürs fußvolk dazu
sagen und dann ist da gleich stimmung in
der bude
da sind wir wieder bei dem thema wunsch
zu kunst für dich ist das eine wirkliche
kunst hast du da machst auf der bühne
kunst im sinne von künstlichkeit und
kunstfertigkeit ja ja ja ich nenne das
ist dann welche rausgehen und sagen so
jetzt fängt die vorstellungen an und
gedanken geschichten präsentieren
mitnehmen falsche fährten legen usw und
dich dich berühren also der mann großes
anliegen ist auch die menschen im
programm zu berühren doch nicht nur
lachen und hh sondern auch das ist ein
emotionales erlebnis gibt das ist eine
sinnlichkeit hat dass du nicht nur
längst intellektuelle durch steige ich
das jetzt mal dass du auch berührt wird
das dein herz angesprochen empathie
wenn alle stricke reißen kann so
nachrichten
danke auch